please welcome Pamela Anderson oh my God
I'm so excited I can't even tell you how
much I wanted to talk to you oh that's
so cute the video you sent me was so
sweet and I thought she's so I do feel
like a kindredness some kind of
something with you yeah because I've
always just thought you were such this
Wild Flower we're wild flowers wild
flowers and ever since we started this
show and there was an opportunity
planted in my head like a seed in a
garden I started reaching out to you
because I kept thinking I would give
anything to have a conversation with you
and it was a pandemic it was a weird
times and then I was having weird times
back then too yeah I was on the ranch
doing who knows what I drinking beer
great fat well it's ridiculous I was
just I'd given up again
a time or two what was that one about
for you yeah you know I felt like I was
like a spawning salmon like coming home
to die I was just like just get me home
I just don't everything was just
compounding you know when things happen
and even relationship after relationship
it's not just it accumulates it's not
just one disaster after another there
they add to the last disaster and I just
felt like I just want to go home I I
bought my this little farm from my
grandmother 30 years ago 25 years ago
and I thought I just need to go home and
renovate and not meet anybody of course
met the contractor he was cute married
him that didn't last long but still why
do I do that it's like unconscious
desire to be noticed and seen I said
geez I've got so much you know it's my
actions that really propelled me into
thinking I just need to I need to go
back from the beginning like when was I
normal when before weird stuff started
happening to me when I need to go back
to that five-year-old child and so I
started putting her picture everywhere
and I wanted to Broadway I put her
picture on the mirror and I said she's
going to do Broadway and I'm just going
to get out of the way and it was so
powerful I mean it's a crazy exercise to
picture yourself at five years old from
head to toe and Embrace that person and
tell them that they're going to be okay
and get through everything it's just
self-awareness self-exploration
self-education because you know I was
not an educated me neither an educated
person I would go to school right well
yeah you had a long career set school we
all know what that looks like Yeah well
my school was my University was a
Playboy Mansion so I just think okay
well that was kind of mine too also I
learned a lot there I've learned that
there are such thing as philanthropists
and art and and gentlemen and chivalry
and as crazy as you know people really
want me to always
you know they want me to say something
bad about it but I didn't have a bad
experience that was so much better than
where I had come from I felt like when I
was doing Playboy I was taking my power
back which is what you said in the
documentary yeah but when I was doing
like Playboy and being a wild child and
being free and discovering myself and
growing up right you know I mean we were
growing up We Were Young how old were
you when you came from Canada to America
in my early 20s okay like I was 10 years
old I landed on gay pride day I was like
I called my mom there's parades here
every day he didn't want to go to the
game but you ended up going and they
discovered you oh that game yeah I know
it's been a faded you rode with the limo
driver you were his passenger you didn't
get in the back right I didn't want to
get in the back I love you I love you
and why didn't you want to get in the
bath oh I just didn't think it was and
anyone to talk to you about there I mean
I wanted to be in the front my mom does
the same thing I realized that when I
picked her she picked up my driver would
say yeah your mom rode in the front with
me too she went right to the back
and you talked to me about something
that I didn't think about and I heard
you say it and I I never in my life
had anyone say this when I was doing
Playboy and loving it and having so much
fun and don't regret a thing and love it
I didn't know I'd have kids later yeah
right we don't do things in your life
thinking this is going to humiliate or
embarrass my kids when I have them if I
have them you know and so yes I knew
Playboy was going to be
you know once I had kids I was like oh
gosh and then I brought the kids to the
Playboy Mansion every Easter and I was
getting the car and Brandon came out Mom
do you know what Heff does for a living
I was like oh God what and he goes he
takes pictures of naked girls and I was
like oh my god get in the car let's get
out of here
okay I know this sounds like a weird
like there's so many things I want to
talk to you about but like then I was
watching you with Matt Lauer and I went
to this moment where I remember him
I came on to the Today Show and he said
you know I want to know why Charlie's
Angels 2 is such a flop basically
and I never had a boundary I always
turned it into a Plucky situation we've
learned how to smile our way through
things and just that was funny I would
actually like to be like you the way you
said to Jay Leno
when he said if you could be anybody who
would you want to be and you said you so
that I could ask me these questions or I
could talk about me differently that's
the spiritual way yeah well I mean you
just you handle things the best you can
I mean we all just do the best we can
and and this was a crazy business for me
I never knew anything about it I know I
came from a little tiny town and on
Vancouver Island and I was just
experiencing everything and learning
everything and learning oh this is the
way it is but I was like Mr Magoo I mean
there are some things where I just
somehow I could have I could have been
so much worse it could have been so much
worse so I had Angels or something and
and now it feels so Redemptive I've
never felt in my life that I've been
rooted for you know and I feel like I
root for you oh thank you but I know but
this is new feeling to me and this is a
new feeling to me did you ever write a
book did you write a book yes I did
called Wildflower and that's why you and
I are wild flowers
wildflowers you are a wild but you know
I didn't realize how angry I was until I
wrote my book when I actually went back
into those chapters and and I wrote my
book myself I didn't have a Ghostwriter
I did it all myself and I felt like it's
just it just was unearthing this
volcanic kind of anger I had but I got
to experience that my poor editors I was
like Exorcist on my head was spinning
pea soup everywhere I was like angry I'm
a girl and I was like oh I needed to
release that I referenced Reagan from
Exorcist every day of my life yeah like
a few head turned yeah really strange
connected I was really looking for it
when you sent me that and my kids
watched the video that you sent me and
they're like she is your new best friend
okay okay we're Clearly Now best friends
this is exactly what I hoped for
[Music]